um you okay being a part of Skip Bayless
he leaves ESPN obviously him and uh
Stephen A Smith have this legendary show
for all these years
somehow the magic gets recreated but in
my opinion much better I think him and
Shannon are I just love them together
more than I I love the Stephen a thing
but you're there on day one
what because that that's a big I
remember how big of a deal it was that
skip left and it was just like oh
there's something going on here and
you're kind of you're there so like what
was it like early uh early when it comes
to just seeing those two form their
chemistry and just that whole entire
time in sports media it was a really
really incredible experience especially
to be the part of like you said a big
story and launch right it's always cool
to launch a show but when you're
launching a show with a Hall of Famer
and Shannon sharp and Skip Bayless like
the Skip Bayless and everyone's watching
to see what the chemistry is going to be
like and how's it going to look and you
know is it going to work are they going
to get ratings and it was it was really
a wild thing to be a part of we shot a
bunch of commercials there were all
these promo shoots and there's these
Billboards and you know stories going on
and it was also the first time that we
had done a show together so that part of
it also like behind the scenes getting
into the Beats of a show as
as structured as a debate show in that
format is is a whole other challenge to
do because as you know it gets heated on
that show it does and you have to be
able to balance what we're talking about
is just about this and not personal and
then you have to move the show along and
you're kind of like an adult in the room
kinda well I'm moving everything so like
we got to get the commercial break like
when do I jump in to cut him off so that
he feels like he's had everything he had
to say so there's a lot of moving Parts
but it was it was an amazing experience
we traveled a lot we went to McGregor
fight in New York we were at the
McGregor Mayweather fight we were at the
US Open we were at the NBA finals in
Cleveland the NBA finals in Oakland the
Super Bowl so it was a really incredible
incredible launch and it was a great
experience working with both of them and
I mean we had a we had a lot of fun on
that show is do you think Skip gets a
bad rep sometimes because he genuinely
Timmy comes off like a nice guy like
he's I just think that you know he's so
dug in on some of his I mean he's
opinion is right so I don't ever tell
people how to how they should feel about
anyone I I know what my experiences are
with them Skip's always been extremely
generous with me a great mentor he's
given me some some great advice over the
years he's gives strong opinions and
sometimes most of the time people are
going to disagree with your opinion
right that's what the opinion space is
so I don't really find that it's
particularly unique to just skip because
I've worked with Skip and I've worked
with Shannon and I've worked with Colin
and I work with other opinionists now
and I worked with big Personalities in
Miami
that's what you're doing if you're
giving your opinion the reality is most
people aren't gonna like what you have
to say I mean I deal with it now I get
my opinion every day I know people
aren't going to like what I have to say
sometimes right and that's fine because
that's what my opinion is now I think my
delivery is maybe a little cheekier than
skips but you know that's that's his
style and he's he's okay with people
disagreeing with him were you there the
first time Shannon pulls out a goat mask
on TV
um I think it was yes yes because he we
actually ended up bringing in an actual
goat into Studio one time so it had to
have been after the goat mask because he
was wearing the Jersey the first time
because he's so funny he's worn it so
many times I've lost track but I think
the first time he had a jersey on yeah
and and and and then he had the goat
master and then the goat mask yes and
then yes and then he because we brought
an actual goat into the studio like a
real actual goat so that had to have
been after it I just love like how he'll
bring weed on the set and he'll be like
skip this ass
I was like this is this is amazing like
like if you would have told me like 10
years ago that Shannon sharp would be
bringing some uh some tree on the side
some tree and cognac on live TV it's
just we have a lot of abilities who
really dig into our personalities over
there which is fun like you can really
you can really be yourself and that's
that's what people relate to is when you
are enjoying yourself you know it's
television or you're doing an interview
or anything you're always going to be up
a little bit you know it's not like when
you're showing at your house having a
conversation but people want to
enjoy the show you know especially with
a show that you're being very combative
and you're having really serious
conversations sometimes and you're
having really
um deep arguments and debate you add a
little lightness to it every once in a
while you know do a little do a little
gloating you know pay the Pay The Man in
Diet Mountain Dew and you know and enjoy
the show